well look I I you came out against what
Trump tried to pull off which was
stealing an election so you know you're
kind of to me a Liz Cheney Republican
like I I said all along even though I
wasn't very supportive of you being very
supportive of Donald Trump which you
were
at the end of the day I said there are
certain Republicans who have a safe word
like they'll let him get away with
absolutely anything and it turned out
that safe word was democracy and people
like
I mean when he tried to
literally steal the election I mean you
he asked you first you were the head of
the justice department look into it see
if there's any truth to the fact that
and of course this was one of the most
honest well-run elections ever and you
told him I think you said it's
and you resigned so you're on that list
Jenny page where you know what I call as
As Good As It Gets Republicans I mean
that the best way
but you say you still would vote for
Trump again
well what I've said when confronted with
the question if Trump is the party's
nominee and he's running against Biden
who would you vote for and I said it's
hard for me to see
uh I just find it hard to to believe
that I could vote uh against the
Republican nominee under those
circumstances because I think the main
threat to the United States and the main
danger to our democracy frankly is uh
the the sort of radical Progressive
Movement and the Lurch to the left that
that has taken place over the last more
than the guy who you actually said tried
to steal an election really more more
important than that what happens in our
country on a daily basis makes the
McCarthy era look like Childs I know but
if we don't if it's not a democracy is
it still even speech is essential to
democracy just like voting if someone
says what's the major danger now to
democracy
I I agree elections are critical in the
right to vote is critical but the thing
that's most under attack is public
discourse which is essential it's it
precedes voting
okay well look
I'm glad that we could disagree on a
thousand things yeah that's okay because
again neither one of us is going
anywhere right so you know I'm glad that
we're going to be friends and we can
laugh at you the one I must say the one
thing I I kind of like hold against you
is when the Mueller report came out I
feel like you mischaracterized it and I
feel that was shady here and I'm going
to read you the Mueller report came out
and you said the evidence and of course
you didn't have to do this this report
spoke for itself and Mueller also
released a a yes A redacted version that
you could have used you said the
evidence developed by the special
counsel was not sufficient to establish
that the president committed an
obstruction of justice offense that's
not what Mueller said he said if we had
confidence that the president clearly
did not commit obstruction of justice we
would have so stated could I vote so I
feel like that was shady Bill okay
and I just had to get that off my chest
can I respond yes of course I brought it
up all right
on March 5th when he came in and told me
what he was planning on doing I said you
have to give me a report that I can make
public quickly it has to be redacted
because the day you give me the report
everyone's going to be speculating I
read he did give you that no he did not
okay so when he came in and by the way
there was no pressure for him to give in
on any day certain he could have taken
his time and redacted it but let me get
the facts out because people are very
quick to jump to conclusions they don't
know the facts
so uh he came in and they gave us on
Friday the report unredacted it was
illegal to put it out it was estimated
to take two to three weeks to redact it
I couldn't sit on that the media was
going crazy Talking Heads were talking
about how the president was about to be
you know go to jail and so forth we
couldn't have that happen to the market
to our foreign adversaries overseas but
he but I felt that I had to say
something to give the bottom line of
what he decided number one I said he
found there was no collusion it's like
going out and announcing a verdict I
didn't Regale the whole trial but I said
he said there was no collusion well you
framed it as he was innocent and then
everything else no I didn't argued
against that and then he said we can't
come to the conclusion that he didn't
obstruct Justice and you said he didn't
obstruct Justice no well I I invite
people just go and look at the yeah well
the only read part of it the I I first I
said what he did I said he sets forth
the facts on 10 episodes which he
believe are potentially obstruction he
does not reach a conclusion he States
colon that he does not find there was
obstruction but he is not exonerating
the president all right okay I used his
exact language then I said he punted
but I'm making the decision
and I say based on that report there was
no obstruction and the discussion about
how there was no obstruction was not me
characterizing Mueller but me stating my
conclusion
so those are the fact well I'm going to
shake hands with the guy who resigned
when Trump tried just thanks a lot